ليس لديهم فكرة عنها وعباس
يؤدي الظروف التي يعيشها الناس
ليخجلوا منهم
هذه المساهمات تجعلك كله
فصيل حزبك بأكمله
لا أعتقد أن هذا لا يكفي
أنني هناك أو أن هناك اثنين وثلاثة آخرين
الناس في مكان ما في السياسة الفيدرالية
أو على مستوى الدولة أعتقد ذلك
من المهم جدًا أن الأشخاص الذين لديهم
قصتي مع قصتنا
ممثلة أيضا في السياسة
ال
لا أعرف أي نوع من الأفكار
لديك من الناس ولكن هل تؤمن
بجدية أن الناس طواعية
اذهب و مت
كان لدينا كل الوقت إلى الوراء و
لدينا منزل ولكننا كنا
لم يسبق أن مارل هذا هو المنزل
والدي وبالطبع هذا أيضًا
لكن جزءًا مني يمكنه القيام بالأرض
لا وأخواتي أيضًا
[موسيقى]
لم يكن لدي حتى ذلك الحين
أدركت بشكل صحيح أنني كنت في واحدة
يعيش مخيم اللاجئين تقريبًا لأنني هناك
ولدت وفقط عندما خرجنا
هل لاحظت بعد ذلك على ما يرام مع الآخرين
يعيش الأطفال الألمان بشكل مختلف
[تصفيق]
نعم ، وضع مليء بالخوف والذعر
هذا المنزل الحقيقي
لابتزاز ألمانيا
[موسيقى]
لا يزال لدي في دائرتي اليوم
احترم ذلك فقط أمي
أيضا وقاتلت من خلاله مرة واحدة
وحصلت على واحدة من خلال أربع فتيات
الاتهام مرارا وتكرارا
هذا بسبب لون بشرته
بطريقة ما سيكون أو بطريقة ما شيء
لن تجعلها أو أقل موهبة
هي وبيانات وكلمات مسيئة
لذلك كل هذا حدث دائمًا
[موسيقى]
كان لدينا قبل بضعة أشهر فقط
كان هناك الكثير من حزمة الهجرة
لقد حدث تفاقم من هذا القبيل
سيجعل الحياة الجحيم مرة أخرى
الكثير من الناس هنا
في الواقع وهذا يخضع للترحيل على سبيل المثال
هذا هو ذلك على الإطلاق
أداة بالنسبة لي سياسيا شخصيا
إذا كان سيئا فظيعا أعتقد ذلك
يجعل الأمر مهمًا تمامًا و
من الضروري أن المزيد والمزيد من الناس
استخدام لهذه المواضيع
بعض الناس في هذا
المجتمع بسبب دينهم
أو الأصل بسبب الطريقة
وافقوا كيف يتكلمون
لتكون شركة عاملة الآن
أحاول القيام بذلك على المستوى السياسي
للقيام به كموضوع وإغلاق الأشياء هناك
يتغيرون